hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
vasoactive intestinal peptide
so this is a peptide hormone which is a
local hormone found in the gi tract
and it has a vesoactive properties in
the intestine
so chemically vasoactive peptide
is 28 amino acid long polypeptide chain
and this is very similar to glucagon or
secretin
so basically it belongs to glucagon or
cyclogene superfamily
and it binds to specific g protein
coupled receptor present
on the target cells now vip
is produced in many tissues of
vertebrates
including pancreas intestine
and also in the brain it is synthesized
by the supraoptic nucleus of
hypothalamus
so we would look at the functions of vip
and what are the
roles that it play in the body
so half life of vip is very very short
it is only
available for two minutes after that it
is degraded
so vip tells us that
within particular time frame the hormone
can
act specifically now let's talk about
the functions of vip
in the digestive system vip seems to
induce
muscle relaxation in the esophageal
sphincter stomach and
gallbladder and then
vip also induce secretion of pancreatic
juice
and bile it cause inhibition of gastric
acid secretion
while in the intestine its role is to
stimulate the secretion of water and
electrolytes
so these are the major functions of vip
now vip also functions to stimulate
the peptic cells or the chief cells
such that they can secrete pepsinogen
and thereby vip indirectly aid in the
protein digestion
vip seems to be an important factor in
context of inflammatory bowel disease
about inflammatory bowel disease i would
be having a different video but right
now
let us understand that vip is really
important in context of bowel disease
vip is also found in heart and it has
significant effect
on cardiovascular system it causes
coronary art
coronary vasodilation and
it has positive ionotropic and
chronotropic effect
so it is also found in brain especially
in the supraoptic nucleus of the
hypothalamus
so vip has functions on pituitary gland
as well
so vip in pituitary ultimately help in
prolactin secretion
so i hope that summarize uh everything
about vip if you like this video
you can give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe
and you can support me and my channel in
patreon
if you want to access my courses in an
academy you can use my code a p10 to get
a 10
discount till then see you in the next
video
and thanks for listening please let me
know in the comments how you like my
video thank you